well actually I don't appropriate logos
and symbols but you could say that I
appropriate the aesthetic and so I go
through a sketch process to develop each
individual drawing so if you looked at a
at a painting and extracted just one
symbol there's a development process
that goes into developing just and
creating just that one that one drawing
and so well like I was saying earlier
when I was growing up in Virginia Beach
I realized that realize the power of
icons and logos and symbols and how they
could transform otherwise ordinary
objects by by increasing their perceived
value and so I really that want to
assume that power for myself and so
instead of simply appropriating logos or
icons that are anonymously created by
corporations to stand for symbolize you
know any any number of goods and
services I really want to take that
again kind of that power and use it to
communicate my own thoughts ideas or
concepts and do so with with an
authorship that is accountable and
responsible for that image and so it's a
it's a subversion in a kind of voice a
version of an aesthetic again whereby
I'm using that those forms which is
essentially how I learn to draw by going
through a design program I learned how
to create logos and icons and all of the
requirements that those entail for
instance they have to be read quickly
there's a notta to not everything that
all the images are kind of distilled
down to the essential forms and their
art there isn't a wide range of
scale shifts and details within one
drawing because each little icon has to
be reproduced a number of different
sizes so it really has to hold up at
different at different sizes so there
are a lot of different requirements that
go into making these kind of drawings
and again I wanted to kind of as you
know soon that power for myself to
communicate my own you know hopefully
more poetic ideas than just you know
whatever you know you would see in our
environment and iconic symbol
symbolizing something in a very kind of
blunt and pedestrian way because that's
the goal so hopefully you know when you
look at a lot of my drawings that again
are kind of embedded in the paintings
you do a double take and they
communicate more than they then they
seem to it first
maybe I've kind of become numb to it and
I think it was a hotter topic maybe five
or ten years ago and the fact that it's
not so much but it's you know is is is
very telling and almost scary but but
but I think I you know I believe in a
kind of fight fire with fire approach so
again that is the world of course that
we experience in our daily lives and as
a reaction I want to create my own world
that I want to share with other people
at almost as an alternative to these
other worlds you know so if you could
immerse yourself in in my world with you
know through all the different things
that I make hopefully it could be more
rewarding you know and in the end i'm
not trying to sell you anything you know
just just share some share some ideas
well I have a corporation I have Ryan
McGinnis Studios incorporated and I've
owned other small businesses maybe since
high school I think I started my first
corporation so I'm not necessarily
against corporations I guess what I more
accurately I think what I would be
against or its people's relationship to
corporations and corporations
relationships to people even to the
extent we're aware by corporations have
a lot of ways more rights than
individuals and i think it's it's scary
when this when a society is set up to
give corporations more rights then then
it gives rights to individuals so
corporations in and of themselves i'm
not necessarily against their kind of
necessary legal entities to an end can
and can do you know great wonderful
things for humanity but i think it's how
people react to corporations and how
corporations react to people on a very
kind of human level that's not that's
something to be worried about